ecclestone estrosi qui va donc
s'installer bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous on dirait que ce matin
christian estrosi êtes notre invité
politique maire de nice on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par la presse
locale votre presque local festin
estrosi denis carot bonjour deniers
bonjour beaucoup d'être avec nous
directeur des rédactions de nice-matin
on va parler de ce congrès des maires
christian estrosi qui se tient
actuellement porte de versailles
emmanuel macron qui reçoit donc des
maires à l'elysée ce soir dont vous il
prononcera demain discours de clôture du
congrès annuel c'est le dernier du
quinquennat quinquennat de
l'incompréhension pour vous entre les
maires et le chef de l'état moi non je
n'ai pas ce sentiment
le président pendant tout ce quinquennat
nous a souvent consultés
je fais partie de ceux auxquels il a
demandé quelquefois des avis n'a pas
toujours tenu compte d'ailleurs mais
sur un grand nombre
c'est patent c'est plutôt que notamment
en matière de décentralisation
nous avons été confrontés au fond 1 un
changement de paysage important
il ya quatre ans est
entré de manière effective la loi sur le
non cumul et savent à public sénat il se
trouve qu'il n'ya plus un seul maire en
france qui siègent ni au sénat ni à
l'assemblée nationale donc tout cela a
changé la nature des relations entre
l'exécutif
le législatif
et ceux qui font la vie quotidienne des
françaises et des français à savoir les
maires donc je pense qu'il ya quelque
part
un dysfonctionnement dans le sens qu' il
faut trouver dans les années qui
viennent le moyen que de
nouveau il y ait des maires qu'ils
puissent participer au débat national
sans don de temps sur cette loi sur le
non non non moi personnellement je ne
demande pas je trouve que c'est bien
qu'un maire se consacre à 100% à sa
commune et je suis de ceux qui ont fait
le chantre leur mandat parlementaire et
ce mandat et je ne regrette pas du tout
et comme et alors que les maires
puissent participer aux débats nationaux
qui ont une influence sur leurs
responsabilités quotidiennes vis-à-vis
de leurs administrés donc pas
d'incompréhension pour vous y compris
sur la question de la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation qui est beaucoup
dénoncé par les maires de france sur la
question de la décentralisation oui mais
il ya une réalité moi j'ai défendu en
tous cas cette mesure face justement à
l'association des maires de france c'est
que le rôle d'un maire sait défendre ses
administrés or il se trouve que sous ce
mandat personne ne peut le contester il
y a eu un gain de pouvoir d'achat pour
95% des français puisque celui ci a
augmenté en moyenne 1,6 pour cent à
raison de 3 197 euros par an et c'est
passé par quoi s'est passé notamment par
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
qui a supprimé 19 milliards d'euros sur
ce que payer les français pour se loger
c'est important quand même écart
vous partagez pas écoutez moi le lien
avec mes administrés il passe
naturellement par
la taxe foncière
il passe par la relation que nous avons
sur l'usagé services publics et la
contribution qu'ils y apportent
la taxe d'habitation est quelque chose
de totalement relatif c'est même un
impôt qui était injuste dans le sens que
quelque selon la ville dans laquelle
vous habitiez à paris où elle est une
des moins chères de france parce que
c'est l'accord on a le plus de
ressources et des petites villes de
province où elle est beaucoup plus chère
avec le même revenu ou payer plus de
taxes d'habitation c'était donc pour moi
une mesure fiscale totalement injuste et
je me réjouis que le président de la
république est rendu du pouvoir d'achat
à nos concitoyens comment un maire
peut-il et c'est ce que je reproche mois
l'association des maires de france dire
je ne veux pas qu'on fasse gagner du
pouvoir d'achat mes administrés en leur
supprimant la taxe d'habitation pour moi
c'est incompréhensible alors qu'ils ont
besoin qu'on leur rende leur
l'association des maires de france
justement un christian estrosi on
connaîtra cet après midi le nom du
successeur de françois baroin cette
association est ce qu'elle est encore
influente est importante
vous savez moi je n'aime pas tirer voilà
la mf représenter il y a quelques années
vraiment un lieu de dépassement qui
devait défendre les territoires de
france
et pas un lieu
qui soit un syndicat ou les mères
défendre leur propre statut les français
attendent de nous
aujourd'hui on voit bien
que petit à petit ça s'est transformé en
un espèce de syndicat d'opposition à
tous
[Musique]
plutôt que de propositions qui pèse dans
le débat national auquel je souhaite que
les mères puissent participer
la désaffection de ce congrès cette
année ou pour ceux ayant l'habitude de
le fréquenter il ya quatre à cinq fois
moins de participants qu'il n'y en avait
les précédentes années les maires ont
préféré rester chez eux vous savez ce
matin ou interrogé ma préoccupation
c'est pas de savoir ce qui va se passer
à la mf dans la journée ou ce soir ma
préoccupation ce sont les chiffres du
cor vide du code qui va se passer à
l'est mais aujourd'hui puisque la mmf a
désigné son président aujourd'hui il ya
un duel entre david lisnard le maire de
cannes et philippe laurent que vous
soutenez le maire de sceaux vous ne
cachez pas de ce soutien renaud muselier
aussi une soutient philippe laurent
alors il a écrit une lettre au maire de
votre région assez virulente envers
david lisnard on va en citer une phrase
le maire de cannes du haut de son tapis
rouge niché dans son palais des
festivals ne pourra jamais comprendre ce
que vous et vos concitoyens vivez au
quotidien dans vos territoires vous êtes
d'accord avec ces mots renaud muselier
elle est allée un peu trop longue mais
je vous ai dit que moi je ne
participait plus mais plus jamais à la
critique de qui que ce soit la renault
muselier mais il faut comprendre les
choses renaud muselier avec lequel nous
avons mené un combat extrêmement
difficile pour éviter l'élection d'un
président d'extrême droite du front
national à la région sud qui était la
région où on pouvait émerger cette
candidature nous avons me monter une
liste de dépassement
républicain bon marche
il vers droite centriste
personnalités de la sécurité des
sociétés civiles et on a réussi à
l'emporter alors que tout le monde nous
donnait perdant
je dois vous dire que mon ami david
lisnard pour lequel j'ai de la sympathie
n'a pas eu une attitude très généreuse
puisque même
il a dénoncé cette volonté de
dépassement dans l'intérêt général
et quelque part naturellement alors
qu'on avait vraiment besoin des soutiens
les mères que nous considérons comme nos
amis il ya eu aucun engagement donc
renault aujourd'hui cette réaction
pour autant ce qui compte aujourd'hui
c'est pas tant celui qui sera élu ce
soir c'est est-ce que ce qu'on en fera
on
nous annonce déjà
je trouve qu'il ya eu une part de
maladresse de la part de françois barois
d'avoir annoncé brutalement
qu' il y avait un successeur auto
désigné dans le cadre d'un accord avec
andré laignel qui représente ce qu'il ya
de plus sectaire du parti socialiste ce
qui peut un peu surprendre alors que les
lits de la démocratie dans notre pays
qui sont les piliers de la démocratie
dans notre pays ce sont les maires
et naturellement le lieu où la
démocratie doit encore plus s'exprimer
ce serait en principe si elle avait
encore une influence aussi importante
qu'elle avait il ya quelques années
l'est mais bon c'est pas le cas et moi
ce soir quel que soit le président qui
soit élu
naturellement s'il s'inscrit dans une
démarche de construction et pas
d'opposition
il pourra compter
sur mon engagement il concluait david et
moi mais quoi qu'il arrive bible j'ai
dit quel que soit ce qu'il soit élu à la
cci n'a pas dit si vous êtes
la seule chose que je veux dire
excusez-moi d'important je mène un
combat politique avec ma propre petite
formation qui s'appelle la france
audacieuse où il ya beaucoup de maires
notamment de la droite et du centre
qui participent et donc nous défendons
des lois de décentralisation le
rendez-vous qui m'intéresse le plus
aujourd'hui c'est celui que nous aurons
avec le président de la république
la parole la plus importante sera celle
qui exprima le président de la
république est ce que celui ci nous dira
je veux que nous ouvrions
omer après les lois de cumul ou de non
cumul qui sont intervenus une part plus
importante aux maires pour participer au
débat national est ce que au delà de la
loi de décentralisation 3ds qui ne
répond pas aux attentes qui étaient les
nôtres le président nous dira j'ai
mesuré à quel point la houle et a pris
des décisions pour lutter dans la crise
sanitaire et
sur des sujets majeurs nous n'avons
réussi au fond mieux que d'autres pays
européens il faut le reconnaître dans
cette crise que grâce à l'agilité et l
engagement des mères à partir de là je
vais donc me lancer dans une grande loi
de décentralisation pour un partage aux
compétences renforcées entre les ars et
les maires
sur l'emploi
en décentralisant pôle emploi vers les
régions sur la sécurité avec une
codirection entre les préfets les maires
ou les présidents d'intercommunalités
le rendez-vous qui m'intéresse c'est
plus celui là que le résultat de
l'élection elle même
ou et christian estrosi le taux
d'incidence remonte dans les alpes
maritimes comme comme ailleurs le port
du masque a été reconduit jusqu'au 1er
décembre dans les alpes-maritimes
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes inquiet
et pour vous quelle est la priorité est
ce que c'est la troisième dose ou le
rappel de la vaccination
denis carot vous connaissez bien la
situation chez nous nous avons été une
des métropoles de france qui a été
la plus efficace
la plus structurée la plus organisé
tentait si bien que même le le recteur
de l'académie de nice à la rentrée
scolaire pour les plus de 12 ans a
demandé à la seule ville de nice à les
vacciner dans tout le département des
alpes-maritimes dans les collèges et
dans les lycées alors que c'est pas de
notre responsabilité
donc fort de cette expérience et de
cette réussite pour les deux premières
injections naturellement aujourd'hui je
veux inciter mes concitoyens aller à
cette troisième injection et je dis très
clairement que les non vaccinés
[Musique]
ne doivent pas faire subir aux vacciner
les conséquences de cette espèce de
repli sur soi
si on devait aller vers de nouvelles
restrictions moi je ne veux pas qu'on
sanctionne les gens qui ont tout fait
pour pouvoir accéder impasse sanitaires
comme en autriche confinement uniquement
pour les non vaccinés si je ne dis pas
un confinement absolue il faudra doser
les choses mais en tout cas nous ne
pouvons plus nous permettre de mettre
notre économie la vie culturelle les
activités de la cité et de nos
territoires sous cloche c'est plus
possible alors que nous avons des
résultats en termes de croissance qui
nous laisse espérer que malgré le
confinement de la première période de
l'année nous finissions l'année dans
notre pays a entre +5 + 6 % de
croissance que dans ma propre ville je
sais que nous sommes sur des chiffres à
peu près égaux à ceux là qui doivent
être annoncés par le directeur général
des finances publiques départementales
on va parler de ces questions budget
mais peut-être une dernière question
avec les sanitaires parce que si je me
souviens bien l'année dernière en début
d'année vous aviez pousser un coup de
gueule sur le nombre de touristes
importants qui sont venus dans votre
ville à noël trop d'avions paraissait de
contrôle dans les aéroports est-ce que
là vous dites pour ces vacances de noël
là il va falloir faire attention à ce
que vous demandez des majeures mais ça y
est aujourd'hui nous voyons bien que dès
qu'il ya
une relance de l'épidémie entre pays de
l'union européenne il y à des décisions
qui sont prises
à l'avenir j'ai vu l'été qui s'est
beaucoup mieux passé que l'été précédent
parce que justement il y avait cette
expérience qui nous a permis de mieux
contenir des afflux que nous n'avons pas
eu parce que nous avons réguler contenu
les choses et que le taux de vaccination
atteint en france qui est supérieure à
la moyenne des autres pays de l'union
européenne grâce à une politique
gouvernementale qu'il faut reconnaître
qu'ils soient sur le plan du soutien à
l'économie en général qui a permis à
tout le monde de redémarrer ce qui n'est
pas le cas dans tous les autres pays de
l'union européenne également à nos
frontières du côté italien ou sur le
niveau de vaccination eh bien nous
sommes mieux protégés que d'autres et
après avoir gagné cette partie il faut
pas au moment où il ya une relance de la
coved perdre la partie en ayant une
troisième injection
ou les niveaux de volontarisme ne soit
pas au rendez vous je note d'ailleurs
que depuis leur reprise l'épidémie j'ai
de plus en plus de gens tous les jours
qui demande à se faire de nouveaux
vacciner pour cette troisième injection
ce qui n'était pas encore le cas il ya
quelques semaines
les députés ont voté le budget hier
parmi les mesures figurent le contrat
d'engagement jeunes annoncées par
emmanuel macron vous avez annoncé que
vous alliez doubler cette somme de 500
euros est ce que ça signifie que le
gouvernement ne va pas assez loin pour
les jeunes ah non ça signifie que comme
sur tous les autres sujets quand
la collectivité apporte une contribution
supplémentaire prenons par exemple
l'économie pour nos restaurateurs nos
hôteliers nos commerçants le
gouvernement a pris des mesures il peut
pas
regardez les caisses de l'état comme un
puits sans fond mais la france est le
pays qui a le plus aidé de toute l'union
européenne ce qui a permis à l'activité
de reprendre et de bien reprendre par
tous bon moi j'ai pris des mesures
supplémentaires par exemple j'ai
exonérés jusqu'à 6 millions d'euros
de
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises là où l'état prenait de son
côté des mesures et bien quand la
collectivité accompagne l'état on voit
que l'activité économique pour tout le
monde est plus porteuse et en même temps
ça ne nous empêche pas d'avoir des
recettes fiscales sans augmentation de
la fiscalité et avec des exonérations
supérieure grâce à la croissance qui est
reparti et bien que le gouvernement dise
plutôt que de laisser des jeunes livrés
à eux mêmes dès lors qu'ils ont un
projet de vie je veux les accompagner
quand certains de ces projets entreront
dans des domaines de compétence de la
collectivité que ce soit
l'intercommunalité où que ce soit la
ville
nous pouvons compléter cela pour assurer
ce jeune de d'avoir plus de chances de
réussite dans son projet de vie pourquoi
irais-je jouer le schtroumpf grognon à
toujours dire pour ce qui est contre et
contre ce qui est pour
ce à quoi ce livre la plupart des partis
politiques jeudi le rôle d'un maire
quand il ya une bonne mesure qui est
prise c'est d'accompagner pour s'assurer
que dans sa commune est bien plutôt que
d'avoir des jeunes qui traînent dans la
rue on leur offre une opportunité
d'atteindre au fond le projet qui est le
leur alors il ya un sujet à nice pour
lesquels il ya des pour et des contres
c'est le prolongement de la coulée verte
c'est le poumon vert de nice pour cela
vous avez décidé de détruire le palais
des congrès acropolis et le théâtre
national national de nice certain si
aussi oppose vous comprenez qu'il ya des
des oppositions où vous êtes totalement
résolue à avancer sur ce sujet c'est un
projet qui existe depuis cinq ans vous
le savez bien denis carot vous me posez
cette question aujourd'hui où elle pas
posée il ya cinq ans
c'était mes procès c'était mais mon
projet de campagne ça et j'ai été élu à
60% c'était là une de mon fascicule de
campagne tous les dix souhaitent êtes
informés
je n'ai pris personne par surprise
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans l'objectif
de -55% de baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre est ce que vous savez
denis carot que ce seul bunker
aujourd'hui qui est un un monstre de
béton dans la ville qui répondait à un
modèle il ya 40 ans et on voit bien que
de partout dans le monde à barcelone à
milan et cetera tous les quarante ans
sur les lieux pour réunir le monde des
affaires les sommer scientifiques etc on
réforme pour s'adapter à l'évolution des
choses on va bâtir une forêt urbaine qui
va prolonger la coulée verte est ce que
vous savez que
simplement ces presque cinq
hectares de superficie qui représente un
îlot de chaleur au coeur de la ville
sans représente dans ce quartier 10 %
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre un
jour peut-on me dire aujourd'hui alors
que ça a été validé par les niçois qui a
eu une concertation publique
on y est opposée je vais
il y avait des opposants aux élections
municipales il continue à y avoir des
opposants aujourd'hui c'est voté par le
conseil départemental par le conseil
régional par la métropole dans le plan
de relance que j'ai signé avec l'état
donc voilà les choses sont en cours
elles vont se faire tout comme on est
opposé pendant dix ans à malines 2 de
tramway dans trois kilomètres en
souterrain entre l'aéroport et le port
est aujourd'hui qu'ils reviendraient là
dessus
les débordements lors lors des mariages
sont à l'origine de drames on a vu
encore samedi avec un jeune qui est mort
dans un accident de voiture vous avez
pris une charte en 2012 pour encadrer
les mariages à nice votre le maire de
poissy a mis en place une caution ils
demandent 1000 euros future mariée est
ce qu'il faut aller vers ce ce type de
mesures non je ne demanderai pas surtout
pour les familles modestes
une caution de ce type mais j'ai été en
france le premier à faire signer cette
charte d'engagement pour les futurs
époux lorsqu'ils demandent un rendez
vous à la mairie pour s'unir d'avoir un
comportement respectueux dans la ville
et vous savez que j'ai été amené à
souvent prononcé moi même et à recevoir
ces futurs époux qui arrivé le jour de
leur mariage
en faisant des rodéos
en se penchant et en s'asseyant aux
portières des voitures en faisant des
demi-tours
prononcer certains mariages à dire vous
n'avez pas respecté la charte cause est
signé et bien le mariage est annulé
on se reverra dans quelques jours
vous fait amende honorable
nous allons naturellement demandé à la
justice de vous sanctionner pour les
délits que vous avez commis et vous est
ce qui vous ont accompagnés et puis si
les conditions sont de nouveau remise à
londres fixera un rendez-vous pour pour
vous unir mais voilà la fermeté dans ces
moments-là il est aussi un temps apporté
tracleer deux petites questions pour
terminer concernant la présidentielle et
votre choix vous avez quitté votre
famille politique d'origine les
républicains vous avez annoncé votre
soutient emmanuel macron on comprend
dans votre discours ce matin c'est très
clair si les candidats s'il est candidat
quel est le sens de ce choix est ce que
vous êtes dit je vais sauter du bateau
avant qu'il ne coule non
ma formation politique
genre est moralement man ou en tout cas
pour moi dont tout le parcours est passé
par le rpr l'ump dont j'ai été membre
fondateur aux côtés de jacques chirac
les républicains que j'ai fondé avec
nicolas sarkozy naturellement je me
reconnais dans cette filiation ils n'ont
pas su tenir et tirer les leçons de leur
échec
ou salé c'est staline qui disait pour se
renforcer il faut ces purées bas à force
de ces purées aujourd'hui on voit où
nous en sommes et quelle leçon vous
dites aujourd'hui c'est fini le parti
républicain vous l'enterrez pas un peu
trop vite je ne veux surtout pas tirer
sur une ambulance aujourd'hui
je regrette simplement qu'on se soit
écarté de nos fondamentaux
ce dont nous avons hérité même si tout
le monde veut se partager son costume
aujourd'hui du général de gaulle de
georges pompidou de valéry giscard
d'estaing de raymond barre de jacques
chirac dans la jupe et de nicolas
sarkozy on n'est plus dans cette
filiation
[Musique]
christian jacob mais lorsque je vois
cette frénésie dans les débats et à
celui qui dit
je veux un grand un hameau
celui qui fait de la surenchère en dix
ans
plus de regroupement familial
et l'autre
l'autre dit mais non mais
le droit le droit du sol c'est fini
zéro immigration dans un pays où on a
besoin malgré tout d'informaticiens
ingénieurs mais je sais pas si vous
suivez les débats moi je suis pas
beaucoup mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est tous c'est pas un c'est tous
aujourd'hui sont tous rentrés dans cette
espèce de surenchère est ce que c'est ça
l'image qu'on doit donner alors que les
grands sujets touchent à la
réindustrialisation de notre pays à
l'objectif à atteindre de moins de 5 55%
d'empreinte carbone naturellement que la
sécurité je suis pas le dernier on reste
sur ce sujet où j'ai souvent pris des
positions assez ferme mais toujours
équilibré bon
voilà lorsqu'on se dit je veux avoir un
discours qui n'est pas celui de monsieur
zemmour ou de madame le pen je me dis
que c'est pas ce que nous un charisme
mais je sais pas les républicains ce
sont des candidats aux primaires
je sais que une grande grande partie des
lecteurs république à
me sont favorables
les enquêtes d'opinion le disent et
naturellement je ne vais pas insulter
une formation politique dont je sais
qu'une grande partie de ceux qui se
reconnaissent encore dans cette
formation politique me trouve des côtés
sans doute rassembleur qui privilégient
l'intérêt général de notre pays aux ego
de certains qui aujourd'hui veulent
exister à tout prix en faisant de la
surenchère au quotidien et donc
naturellement si demain cette formation
politique à laquelle j'ai été très
attachés retrouve la voix de la sagesse
je ne pourrais évidemment mais je ne
pourrai que m'en réjouir tourné lors dès
lors qu'elle accepterait de participer
notamment en période de crise à une
grande politique d'intérêt général pour
notre merci beaucoup merci s1 et s3 et
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
[Musique]